[Music]
it's presidents week here on the Rubin
report and we're partnering with learn
Liberty to bring you five shows in five
days each highlighting a different
President of the United States joining
me today is an associate professor of
history at Sam Houston State and the
co-author of JFK and the Reagan
Revolution a secret history of American
prosperity Brian to be trovich welcome
to the Rubin report it's great to bear
Dmitrievich Dimitra vick usually i said
with a heart state Dimitra vick Demetra
vick okay I was a big fan of drazen
petrovic yeah who is a basketball player
from Croatia and the in the early 90s
but some people said Petro Vic and I
could never tell Rudy Tomjanovich the
old coach yeah it's properly a hot check
at the C so I'm heretical rudakov
knowledge that 95 Houston rocket team is
my favorite basketball team of all time
Clyde Drexler right there there you go
Houston guy do you alright I could talk
basketball the entire time but let's
talk presidents by the title of your
book we could probably talk about Regan
just as easily as we could talk about
JFK who we're gonna talk about do you
have a do the preference out of those
two well our book JFK in the Reagan
Revolution really is two-thirds
three-quarters about John F Kennedy
because we've forgotten that John F
Kennedy paved the way for the Reagan
Revolution in this big tax cut alright
so JFK since you spent two thirds of it
on JFK that's the guy we're gonna talk
about I find with JFK that what it seems
that most at least younger people no say
under 45 is 50 or something like that
they know a lot about the assassination
you know History Channel runs the
documentaries all the time you can watch
the movie JFK zillion other things that
are out there but there's obviously a
lot more to JFK than than just the
unfortunate ending so let's start at the
beginning what do we need to know about
early childhood the the Kennedy family
etcetera Terry let's start with
childhood sure ill John F Kennedy was
born in May of 1917 in a very important
family a family that was becoming one of
the richest in the United States his
father Joseph P Kennedy at that point in
the teens had graduated from Harvard
about ten years before was building his
fortune I would within Kennedy's
childhood before he turned 15 his father
had become one of the richest men in the
country and actually just a peak Kennedy
made most of his money in what we call
the great contraction the worst period
of American economic history from 1929
to 1933 when he short sold the market
and that's really when the Kennedys
became the one of the top richest
families in the United States so how
political was the Kennedy family at that
time yeah I mean it was pretty political
Joseph P Kennedy john f kennedy's father
had married the daughter of an important
boston politician and then Joseph P was
not involved in politics until FDR
Franklin Roosevelt appointed him the
first head of the Securities Exchange
Commission in 1934 and then he became a
big Roosevelt Democrat so that was the
sort of beginning of the dynasty yeah in
the candidate name yes yeah so JFK then
tell me a little bit about sort of his
evolution from a young person to
starting to become a politician yeah so
John
JFK was the second son so there was the
Chesapeake Kennedy jr. who would be
killed in World War two and he wasn't a
good student in prep school and he went
to Princeton actually for a semester
didn't do well there then went to
Harvard did not do particularly well
until his senior year probably
plagiarized his thesis which then
somehow sold 80,000 copies as a book
when it was published but with his
father's help really tell me a little
more about that I haven't heard that one
oh yeah yeah yeah
so John F Kennedy his father in 1938-39
I guess this would have been at that
point was the ambassador to the court of
st. James it was the US ambassador to
Great Britain and was very interested in
the United States fighting the Soviet
Union and not necessarily fighting Nazi
Germany and so that kind of caused
diplomatic problems with FDR's foreign
policy but JFK had extraordinary access
to the files and so he wrote a thesis
that was probably substantially ghost
written about how England was dealing
with the Germany crisis Wow and then and
then it was published as a book and it
sold about 80,000 copies of course
Kennedy would publish another growth
profile is encouraged and Joseph he
would pull strings so it won the
Pulitzer yeah it's good to come from
shamily it is pretty good so tell me a
little bit more about how he then
decided to get into about developing
yeah well I the decisive event really
was the death of his brother in 1944
Joseph Peake Kennedy jr. killed in World
War two because really all the hopes
were on on this son and he apparently
was a very impressive guy if you look at
old pictures of the son Joe he was even
way better-looking than JFK he was kind
of bigger JFK was always kind of skinny
and it really devastated the father when
he was killed in the war and they
realize oh boy Jack he's gonna be the
one where we're gonna have all these
political hopes on and the father did
not have high hopes for Ted at that
point - Robert Robert maybe but right
after Kennedy got out of the war of
course he had his distinguished war
career - he ran for Congress in 1946 his
father pulled a lot of strings and he
won a seat in Brookline Massachusetts he
was in the US House
what does pull a lot of strings mean
because I just find the dynasty part of
this fascinating the idea that they're
sort of grooming children that the power
elite can sort of help people get into
play here well pull a lot of strings in
the 1946 election for example so on the
ballot Kennedy was running against a
particular opponents his father found
somebody else with the exact same name
and put that guy's name on the ballot
and then had a whole publicity campaign
for that guy's name I forget the exact
name to be voted for so that that would
split the vote that takes a lot of money
and a lot of kind of naked ambition so
that's an example the kind of hardball
but he played so that's a slight sidebar
when you hear about all the you know
craziness involved in politics these
days and everyone know it's never been
worse and listen to the way people talk
and all that it's like a lot of shady
stuff has been going on for a long time
well I have no idea how we could look
and say the McCarthy era both how
McCarthy was treated and how McCarthy
treated others and say that politics was
warm and fuzzy back in the 40s and the
50s I have no idea how we could say that
yeah so did JFK do you think he had
presidential aspirations then when he
started this this was sort of thrust on
him and he and he became a congressman
but was here already thinking about that
do you think I think so in that it was
well under
that Joe jr. was going to be something
like President of the United States and
so when that could not happen after his
death I think it became pretty clear to
the sons so there was still Jack Robert
and Teddy left and then I think six
girls that they had to take take that
place and so when he ran for Congress
yeah I mean it was to go onward and
upward yeah so he was a congressman do
you know how many years was he a
congressman right up until he ran from
president he was a US Representative
from Brooklyn Massachusetts from from 46
to 52 and then he won a US Senate seat
in Massachusetts bucking the Eisenhower
trend because he ran on the Democratic
side so he was one of the few Democratic
victories in the 1952 election so then
he was a senator for eight years before
he became president yeah did he have any
major accomplishments as a senator well
that's the interesting thing because
when we ask what were his major
accomplishments as presidents let's say
legislatively yeah
really comes down to maybe one or two
tax cut in the Civil Rights Act so
there's not a lot of like major
accomplishments in the whole Kennedy
biography the funny thing about his
career as a legislator in the Senate in
particular mrs. big enthusiasms were two
things number one he was going after the
mob okay which then his son Rob his
brother Robert would be big on and
number two he was an anti-communist in
foreign policy and that that's how he
distinguished himself as a senator yeah
so it's interesting that the
anti-communist part is interesting
because the parties have shifted so much
these days that I'm not saying the left
ever the Democrats are communists now
but that voice that sort of anti
socialism communism voice would rarely
be heard of from the moderate left which
does tell you how these things have
shifted Joseph P Kennedy his father
became persona non grata in the US
government when in 1938 39 he told
Franklin D Roosevelt from his high
position as ambassador in Great Britain
we don't have to worry about the Nazis
so much we have to worry about communism
because communism can overthrow the
American Way of life I think there's a
pretty direct link there to what his son
was doing in the 50s and 60s that's
interesting so he was he viewed it as
Nazism was in a
little threat not within our borders but
communism actually was something that
could come that was Jose feeling yeah
yeah it was kind of kind of prophetic
even is he was a new dealer and all that
he said well New Deal the New Deal could
help save capitalism that was an
erroneous argument but but Joseph P
Kennedy was worried about the onslaught
against capitalism by communism yeah
interesting so it sounds like the Senate
career was sort of less than spectacular
right it doesn't sound like anything
major happened
I think Kennedy was pretty careful he he
began his Senate career ailing he had
back surgery in 1953 as soon as he
became a senator and could not attend
the Senate he was in fact had to be
reclined for a very long time because of
his back injury and that's when he
decided to write profiles encourage his
1956 book 1955 when the appeal in 1956
about the Great's of the Senate over
time so because he was incapacitated he
wanted a show he was still doing Senate
work by writing about Senate history
right yeah god what a beautiful thing to
be in government you don't really have
to do anything and you can write about
the other guys they've done some stuff
it's it's an incredible thing alright
1960 it becomes president he defeats
Richard Nixon who was vice president at
the time I think the one thing that
people really remember is that debate oh
yeah because he was sort of this young
good-looking guy and there was Nixon
sweating is there anything else we have
to remember from from that elections
yeah that so I there was debate in
September 1960 and people always say
that Nixon won on the radio and lost on
televisions that if people just heard
his words or even read the transcript
that he defeated Kennedy but if he
looked on the television that's
black-and-white television and lots of
viewers Kennedy was the youthful bronze
which is probably from his Addison
syndrome not the suntan hero and Nixon
looked like a schlub yeah I don't know
ironic because it was in black and white
but helps and again that was from one of
his ailments yeah that wasn't from the
South Pacific so I don't know I've read
those transcripts and I think Kennedy
clearly won I mean Nixon was saying
things like oh there's been great
economic growth in this country we're
tipping into a recession right then
400,000 people were about to lose their
jobs in the month of October it makes
saying oh we've had the greatest
economic growth with have we've ever had
under Eisenhower I've been three
recessions under Eisenhower now I think
Nixon lost that debate on the transcript
as well
interesting so just to get a sense of
how parties have changed what was that
what were the basic tenants that JFK was
running on you know so John F Kennedy
didn't know what he wanted to run on
this is a classic Kennedy thing we know
we must be presidents the question is
what are we to run it yeah so it was
really the Democratic National Committee
or the putt that the convention that
summer they kind of defined for Kennedy
he had a lot to do with it of course
what the what he would run on and he
decided he would run that on that the
country was not growing enough and he
made his tag line we have to get this
country moving again we have all these
old slow people and governments and he
kept making the point that we have a lot
of recessions he was right there was a
recession in 1954 big one in 1957 and
then it was coming right then in 1960
and he said we got to get out of this
rut and he kept saying we have to get
this country moving again get this
country moving again so that was his
main thing and then he also talked about
after we out we have to get a little
tougher on communism because we're not
moving enough the Soviets are starting
to pass a spy and those were his big
things so when you say that within a
20-18 context it's hard to believe as I
referenced earlier it's hard to believe
that a Democrat would be running against
sort of slow inefficient government but
that is what he did it's kind of
incredible yeah now the Republicans back
then were the big deficit hawks they're
like okay maybe we've had some
recessions but we have a budget deficit
and we have to keep taxes high tax rates
high so we take care of the budget
deficit wouldn't be prudent in that old
George Bush line I mean that's a very
applicable George Bush came of age in
the 1950s to have economic growth if we
don't take care of our deficit first and
that was the defensive position of
Eisenhower and Nixon Kennedy saw that
and saw an opening and ran with it yeah
so what was the beginning of the
presidency like you know when I watch
all of these documentaries now yeah you
know they talked about it was it's so
much about the family and that there was
this feeling of this young person in the
office and all that I suspect there was
more to it than just that okay so when
Kennedy was elected in November
1960 the United States had just tipped
into a recession there were mass layoffs
of hundreds of thousands in October
probably delivered him the election when
that de Sorenson his advisor Thornton
certainly thought so
and then unemployment went all the way
up increased up to five million by night
by January 1961 so when do you know what
that percentage was just for reference
to stri percent now doesn't sound like
that well five million
yeah sorry five million the workforce
the unemployment rate was probably going
up to about eight percent at that point
I'd have to check but probably around
there okay
so Kennedy took office and it's a snow
storm right that just ended before his
inaugural dress famous inaugural dress
and the big problem was there's now a
new recession and then when he gave a
State of the Union address ten days
later in January 1961 he kind of had a
lot of kind of equivalents a equivocal
statements he said we have to get our
house in order yet our country moving
again and we have the government has to
spend a lot of money so we're kind of
laid out two options we have to kind of
get the government more efficient but
also get the government spending a lot
of money so it was unclear what he was
gonna do yeah what does that even mean I
mean do you think he knew at the time
because those sound like statements that
can't work together Richard Reeves who's
his greatest biographer he wrote the
great book on Kennedy 1992 President
Kennedy he said no no what Kennedy liked
to do and I think this is true we have
all the Kennedy tapes we can hear him on
audio the John F Kennedy Library has
some amazing things online we can hear
so much from Kennedy's voice privately
it's pretty clear that he thought
himself kind of the uber intellectual
not a philosophical intellectual but
somebody who could process thoughts and
he would get a lot of good advice and
then pick the best option so that's the
way he would operate he wasn't gonna
figure it out himself he was gonna wait
and see and then make a strategic
decision so you think when he brought up
those seemingly conflicting ideas that
he actually did mean it and that
eventually he he would widdle it away
with the right people behind it and now
this sort of gets to to what your book
was about which one did he end up going
for okay and and
this good you went for both okay so
Larry Keller and I wrote this book JFK
in the Reagan Revolution about the John
F Kennedy tax cut and the big reason is
what Larry my co-author has had to deal
with for 15-20 years he gets this at
parties from the likes of people like
Caroline Kennedy he gets it on
television CNBC how dare you say that
the John F Kennedy tax cut had anything
to do with the Reagan tax cut because
that tax cut was designed by Keynes
Ian's in order to stimulate demand in
the economy and Larry said I don't think
so
and he's right all right wait little is
cause for just a sec though can you tell
me a little bit about the tax cut
specifically yeah so we have the
framework okay yeah so there was a tax
cut in 1964 so after Kennedy's president
after Kennedy died that was his
brainchild and that actually was his
main legislative accomplishment but he
was president for a thousand days ahead
and he didn't get anything done really
on the economy until he introduced that
tax cut in 1963
so in 61 and 62 he was doing his famous
vacillating that's when he was thinking
about hey the Keynes ears are saying we
need loose money from the Federal
Reserve and we need a lot of social
programs and he was experimenting with
that forecast came in there's gonna be
another recession he pulled back and
said wait we need some more deep
thinking Keynesian said keep doing it
but then pulled in other people what do
you say no we need a big marginal tax
cut I get it when the stock market
crashed in April 1960 to June 1962 he
said ok we need a big marginal tax cut
how powerful was the presidency at this
time you know one of the things that we
talked about on this show alive is just
that the executive branch just keeps
getting more power more power does all
this stuff via executive action a lot of
this when you hear about it I think the
average person thinks wait a minute is
it the president's job really grows to
be doing all this isn't he supposed to
sign the law is not really making the
law right it's interesting on that score
is that John F Kennedy was actually not
terribly interested in making unique
executive actions actually with each of
his executive sign at signing signings
he had these signing statements that
went on and on and on about how
justified his signature was sometimes
now we did they just saw yeah now it's
just ya know he
that signature man so good I think
that's the residents yeah yeah so he
actually rejected a an executive
authority that his liberal advisors were
imploring him to take and that was his
liberal apologist say you should have a
standby tax cut authority you should
have the authority as president just to
reduce taxes on your own for a period of
time maybe up to 18 months so if the
economy starts tipping into recession
you can just sign a piece of paper and
everyone's taxes will go down it'll get
out of recession and then if inflation
starts going up or overheating then you
can take it away and that's effective
and Kennedy said no I'm not gonna do
that yeah that's interesting so I always
described Kennedy as my kind of Democrat
you know I talk a lot about how the left
has sort of lost its way and it's lost
its classical liberal roots and they've
picked progressivism big government over
liberalism do you think his political
ethos I mean from everything I'm hearing
from you so far was he basically came
from a classical liberal line of
thinking right is that is that fair to
say yeah I mean Kennedy ultimately it
sounds like there was definitely some
play on both sides yeah Kennedy
ultimately did some very good things as
president above all the tax cut you
could argue the civil rights act even
though like I still kind of think and
Kennedy believed and we can talk about
this later if you like that if the tax
cut had just happened the civil rights
that would have been unnecessary we can
talk about that later yeah the thing
though about Kennedy is he was kind of a
wild man I mean he was a rich wild man
and I don't know how useful that
particularly is in our political life
his father was kind of crazy about what
he did how he felt he could influence
politics and his son was kind of a chip
off the old block although his son was
incapable of making money unlike his
father but they were both pretty wild
people in kind of in charge of the
United States government that might be
an argument for shrinking government
yeah all right so when you say wild I
mean we hear all kinds of stories and
rumors and all this and that I mean what
what are you saying wild is or was yeah
we Larry and I talked a bit about a girl
he dated
Margaret quoits who won the Pulitzer
Prize in biography and history she wrote
a biography a great biography of John
Calhoun 1950 and when the peeled
surprise then Kenny wanted to get to
know her because he wanted to win
appealed surprise too and we have her
recollections of the time when she dated
Kennedy right before he he proposed to
Jackie in 1953 and she said you know
he'd just drive around in the convert
convertible and making sure he was
staying on streetcar tracks just
annoying people on the road and he was
saying I want to do this I'm going to do
this I just realize just got just a
little bit out of my league
he was a force of nature so alright
there are some people who are forces of
nature so I just think from a certain
perspective that might be a reason if we
have government to make sure that if we
have those people at the top of
government government should be small
mm-hmm
all right I want to do a lot more on the
taxes and I don't want to get to civil
rights but we should back up a little
bit because I haven't mentioned Jackie
at all I actually just watched the movie
with Natalie Portman oh yeah I thought
it was excellent what do we need to know
about their relationship the courtship
and then the amount of power that she
had or at least the uncomfortability
with with being the first lady and then
subsequently after after he was
assassinated yeah Jackie the first guy
who proposed to Jackie just died a year
or two ago in his home on Nantucket in
Massachusetts and Jackie turned down his
proposal this is in 1951 or 52 because
she and her mother did not think that he
would end up being rich enough and I
point out that he died on Nantucket but
I think she was right even he was would
not have been rich enough well no I
think not Jackie can it that that's hard
to believe but people don't really
understand what that sort of northeast
what do you call that it's not even
elite it's something else right just
that that family dynasty thing where
these people really were connected with
other people for the purposes of
politics and power it's it's hard to
believe it I think it mattered to us I
know but I think what really calmed
Jackie down they were a great love match
I don't think there's any dispute about
that Jack and Jackie but what really
settled Jackie was Joseph peace wealth
Jackie really adored JFK's father adored
him
and his $400,000,000 calmed her down so
I think that was at the absolute glue
that kept them together right and she
came from a lot of money right I mean
the movie has had money yeah they then
this is divorce and she was married and
she brought into the Auchincloss family
which was very involved the senator from
New Jersey Auchincloss representative to
who voted for the Kennedy tax cut in
1960 1960s Louis Auchincloss the famous
novelist but they they had been harmed
by the 1929 crisis and the Kennedy
family had been immensely enriched by
the 1929 crisis so there was a big
wealth gap banana's families so
everything that I've seen about I
haven't read much about her but I've
seen I watched Grey Gardens a jazzy
movie in everything that she really
struggled with the the public nature of
this really from day one but she also
knew what she was marrying into is that
just a little bit about the complexity
of her character well Jack he was a this
no question she was a sophisticated
person I mean she spoke French and
Spanish and all that because she was
interested in the ways of the world
and she really was one of the most
remarkable fashion plates in all of
history and she stepped into those roles
very well so it yes she was shy she has
that little voice that you can bury the
mountain barely hear but she also
understood what her potential was her
potential was to be an ambassador for
civilization and she stepped into that
very very willingly and it's good that
she did yeah okay so now let's jump back
we're gonna do a little more in her but
let now let's jump back to those tax
cuts yeah so you're saying that JFK put
those tax cuts into place 62 63 but then
they weren't enacted until after he was
gone so tell me a little bit more what
happened is it he didn't put those tax
cuts in place I'm afraid in 61 and 62 he
listened to his liberal advisors who
said we have to concentrate on
government spending
hold off on tax cuts let's just
concentrate on government spending let's
get loose money from the Fed and maybe
welfare programs spend on national parks
at post offices all bunch of stuff and
that'll stave off recession that'll
stave it off that'll stave it off and if
we invest in education and hospitals and
Medicare and welfare the economy will
grow
because of that government investment
that was the argument of his liberal
advisors Kennedy did that for the first
year and a half all the forecasts came
in and said oh there's gonna be another
recession there's been there were four
recessions in the 1950s in 1949 54 57 60
let me have fifth and thirteen years
every 24 months 36 months is gonna be a
recession when the stock market went
down 30% in the spring of 1962 Kennedy
said leave me another recession I'm
gonna be so run out of office it's not
funny
yeah we're gonna switch gears here and
that's when he gave his commencement
speech at Yale in June of 1962 saying we
have to think about reversing our policy
mix towards tight money to protect the
dollar and tax cuts to expand the
economy and then what happened what was
the result then is liberal advisors said
wait wait wait it's going great don't
listen to that we're gonna do their
argument the way that when they were
looking at the numbers you know what was
the argument just purely like operating
on a philosophical level if you just
keep throwing money at the government in
these programs a waives academic
articles
they had Paul Samuelson at MIT and
Robert Solow two future Nobel Prize
winners whose staff at the Council of
Economic Advisers saying oh no we've
come up with this thing called the
neoclassical synthesis that says if you
have really loose money from the Fed
that will get the economy moving don't
worry about inflation you can mop it up
with high tax rates and then the revenue
you get confundus and healthcare that
will help the economy grow let's just
stick to it forget about this forecast
for a recession but that that really
reveals kennedy's decision-making
character he listened listened listened
and then just said okay you guys are
wrong we're gonna do the opposite hmm
and that's you know that's real
decision-making metal so then after in
64 when these tax cuts go into place
then what was the result well so there's
still a year and a half there if I may
point out yeah so then in July Kennedy
started talking to his Treasury
secretary big time now he had
communicated with him daily on all sorts
of matters but Larry and I talked a lot
about seed Douglas Dylan the unsung hero
of the Kennedy administration Justice
Richard Chesapeake Kennedy by the way
Kennedy's Treasury Secretary Dylan said
you got to protect the dollar and cut
tax rates that's what you got to do
Kenny went on national television in
August saying by the way that's our
policy
I'm going to
introduced the bill in Congress he did
that in January 63 big congressional
debate almost got passed before the
assassination by that point the markets
and everyone else knew
Kennedy serious about tax Hutton that's
when the huge 60s boom started
what did the parties think of this at
the time because if you think about it
in the context of 2018 Democrats
generally are for higher taxes but
Republicans generally are for lower
taxes so when Kennedy goes out there
listens to the advice and says this it
was it was the party behind him right or
am I looking at this only through our xx
okay no no this is news this is big news
Larry and I talked about this in the
book a lot the party of tax rate cuts
particularly cuts on the top rate of the
income tax the top one now back then it
was 91%
that's unbelievable that's really hard
to fathom at a top rate with 91 I never
said it's so hard to fathom that it has
to be a joke and it was a joke because
nobody paid it no it's true right nobody
paid that rate maybe 20% of people who
should have been that rate should apply
to paid it that's how many loopholes
there were and the Democrats said you
see these rich guys what they're doing
is they're buying off the tax system
they claim they're paying this rate and
then they get all these loopholes and
they're hiding their money and we get a
recession every 24 months because
capitals not deployed correctly so it
was the Democrats Wilbur Mills chairman
of House Ways and Means Committee in
1959 commissioned a huge 2,500 page
study on why we have to cut the top rate
of the income tax and it was the
Republicans who said hey hold it you
know we know what to do we if we say we
need a loophole give us a loophole we're
in charge here so Republicans said no
tax rate cuts the system's working fine
and the Democrat said tax rate cuts to
get us out of the serial recession yeah
what does that say about how things flip
over years and time well I think first
of all we have to blame the contemporary
Democrats Democrats today the last 20
years what are you doing forgetting your
legacy I mean we can go back to the
1820s to realize that the founding of
the party it was about lowering top tax
rates when you talk about the tariff
John Calhoun and Kennedy had a lot to
say about Calhoun through his girlfriend
Margaret Coit Calhoun said yeah tariff
rates hurt
the little guy and then Grover Cleveland
income tax hurts the little guy 1890s
Woodrow Wilson after he raised taxes had
three Treasury secretaries who said
these are completely scarify let's lower
them they're killing investment in this
country for the little guy really you
can go through just about every
Democratic presidents cut tax rates I
mean Bill Clinton cut the capital gains
rate Jimmy Carter cut the capital gains
rate Barack Obama was spooked by the
expiration of the Bush tax cuts and he
kept them from one more year so I mean
there's a long history of Democrats
cutting the top right yeah so then all
right so 64 now the economy starts going
again
Kennedy's gone Oh tell me a little bit
more about the legacy of that okay and
then sort of how that got yeah to Reagan
and then we'll get back okay here's the
basic inflection here the basic numbers
the eight years of the Twite eisenhower
presidency in 1953 to 1961 economic
growth is 2.5 percent okay that's not
good population growth and baby boom was
2.5 percent this is complete stagnation
with three recessions from 1961 to 1969
said the beginning the kennedy
administration through the end of the
Johnson administration economic growth
was 5.1 percent more than double the
rate of economic growth now we believe
it's highly attributable Larry and I to
the policy mix that Kennedy adopted
which is we are going to guarantee the
dollar we're not going to try to get the
dollar off the gold standard no
generally on Nixon would we're gonna
guarantee the dollar so we're not gonna
have loose money from the Fed and we're
gonna get money out there by lowering
tax rates particularly on the rich it
worked it worked as beautifully as any
public policy has ever worked in in
American history all right so let's
change gears a little bit here and talk
about some of the civil rights of
because as all of this is happening and
there's a ton obviously we're talking
about economically mostly the civil
rights movement was was happening I mean
it's been its best cents so I guess
first what was his innate feelings about
the civil rights movement then we'll
talk about some of the specific yeah I
think John F Kennedy was in favor of the
civil rights movement I mean I think he
clearly thought there should be equal
opportunity and a lot of the workouts
that rents that could be found in the
country you know was regrettable and
should be lifted
when it came to policy though he was
characteristically slow-moving so house
over here etc well yeah I mean now we
should note that slow moving might make
sense and that a lot of civil rights
activists argue that the laws are
already on the books I mean there's
nothing we need to do except just be
true to ourselves and all the problems
will be lifted the Freedom Rides he made
phone calls and when Birmingham jail
when Martin Luther King was in the
Birmingham crisis in April in May of
1963 Kennedy wasn't doing a lot aside
from just kind of pressure verbally but
the funny thing about that is that what
a lot of leaders said and a Phillip
Randolph had been saying this for a long
time is that we need jobs yeah it's all
rights is nice but when black out
employments 20% and when you don't have
any shekels to rub together would go to
civil rights so Kennedy started
understand oh if we have a booming
economy a lot of people in this country
including whites are gonna start
relaxing and say sure blacks why is
everything because everyone is well off
and that Kennedy perceived that's one of
the reasons he kept taxes so I know I'm
gonna get some crap for saying this and
but that almost seems like the Trump
view equality that Trump has been
cutting taxes the I think I read just a
couple weeks ago the black unemployment
is at an all-time low right now so he
was sort of taking that that's a page
from the JFK days yeah it is and when I
talk about the Civil Rights Act of 64 65
and 64 when Kennedy introduced in June
of 63 and it was passed I don't know if
the tax cut have been passed if we'd had
a growing economy 5% in the 50s would
we've even thought to have a civil
rights act I don't know because everyone
might have been getting along well
enough that Kennedy kind of came to that
realization and that's a real thing so
if we perceive it today we shouldn't run
away from it that's a--that's a good
Association yeah it's interesting
because I know even just by saying those
two names in the same sentence a certain
amount of people are gonna be angry at
me but that's alright
what was the nature of his relationship
with Martin Luther King because I've
read a bit about it and it sounds like
it was it was kind of complex there were
places where they were lined up but not
all the time well let me answer it this
way what was the federal government's
relationship with Martin Luther King
because J Edgar Hoover of course is
still doing his thing is FBI director
with all the kind of surveillance
probably harassment of Martin Luther
King and Kennedy is paralyzed as
everyone is with the FBI so there's that
I mean Kennedy is not doing anything
about the kind of harassment if Kennedy
know about that do we know if Kennedy
knew that all that was happening I'd
have to look at the files we have a lot
of those remain classified so I'm not
totally sure yeah they have Declassified
some of the stuff just in the last year
right it's exposed a little more of the
surveillance that was happened I'm okay
but what about their personal
relationship yeah I think Kennedy
appreciated Kings intellectualism I mean
there was kind of he brought King into
the White House and then he he watched
the march on Washington from the portico
of the White House kind of peering
around the corner and then invited
everyone back afterwards and he
apparently said I wish I could be out
there with them and enacted chummy with
King but he did kind of keep him at
arm's length I think he was a little
worried about Kings association
invidious or not with communism because
Kennedy was variant anti-common right so
that's interesting because from when
we're taping this it was just a couple
weeks ago that it was Martin Luther King
Day and I you know on that I find it
it's one of the strangest days to be on
Twitter not that you can garner that
much appreciate whitter but where
everyone sort of takes MLK and uses them
for their modern-day political purposes
Eames right so the meme so some people
saying he was a socialist some people
saying he was a communist he was an
environmentalist II whatever you want
him to be within year 2018 lens that's
what people in use but that's really
interesting to me but JFK had this this
idea built in him from childhood as you
were saying about hating communism MLK
had some association at least with sort
of loosely communism or socialism or
certainly had issues with the United
States government and certain levels of
capital
so they did have they were at
loggerheads in some way yeah I think
Kennedy did not want to get burned by
King in other words he didn't want to
kind of bring King into his inner circle
and then King manifests himself as a
flaming communist it Kennedy was way too
cool a character to get burned that way
but by the summer 63 so after the
Birmingham crisis which was the national
outrage on television
can he get heckled in his speeches hey
you're not doing anything about civil
rights yeah and that's when he really
pushed the tax cut in that August and
September 1963 which is when the march
on Washington happened and let's
remember the subtitle of the march on
Washington Martin Luther King a Philip
Randolph's march on Washington was the
march on Washington for Jobs and Freedom
and those are the two sides of Kennedy's
legislative agenda tax cut Civil Rights
Act Kennedy actually felt we believed
that if you had the tax cut early enough
you wouldn't even need the Civil Rights
Act so that's the way kind of Kennedy
walked through this kind of complicated
politics yeah so he really sounds to me
sort of like a politician's politician
he doesn't sound much like an ideologue
specifically and that he really was
listening to the people about him is
there anything else we're missing to
sort of get the full picture on the way
he tried to govern yeah I mean he got
lucky too and I hate to use that word in
this context the most outrageous event
in the history rights movement might be
the berming berm and church bombing in
September 1963 when the four girls were
killed by dynamite that actually made
Kennedy's tax cut because the event was
so outrageous case tax bill was being
voted on in Congress right then the
Southern Democrats did not feel like
they could make a show of defeating
Kennedy's legislation because that event
was so outrageous and then it slipped
through the house and passed right there
so the Birmingham church bombing
actually had a lot to do with the
passage of the kennedy tax cut wow
that's interesting so yeah I know
Kennedy he was okay as a legislator but
I mean he got away with a lot too and he
got a little lucky yeah interesting so
speaking of luck let's talk about the
Cuban Missile Crisis in a little bit
because I guess this really is the well
I guess you would argue that the tax
cuts really are his his biggest legacy
but I think most people think of the
Cuban Missile Crisis so just kind of set
the stage now sure well I just want to
point out in terms of his ledger
slative agenda I don't think it's
disputable that the tax cut was this
most important like maybe Civil Rights
Act but yeah when it comes to foreign
policy yeah thank you Miss Lee now that
playwright the Kennedy's strength I'm
afraid because if it was going to be
clarified there's going to be a contest
between the US and the representative
communists in the Soviet Union the US
was gonna win so that that played right
into his hands okay so that we know that
that's built into him from child:yeah
just give me a Cuban Missile Crisis kind
of 101 a little bit what led up to yeah
and what his decision-making was that
short apiece I wonder so Nikita
Khrushchev is the premier of the Soviet
Union and his new client state in Cuba
if they ever since Fidel Castro had
taken over in 59 and he Khrushchev sent
nuclear missiles to Cuba so they've been
90 miles away from u.s. territory in
Florida when this is discovered Kennedy
tells the Soviets they have to get out
immediately
so he's done a great tension could lead
to the firing of missiles and Kennedy
gets Khrushchev to face down Kennedy
gets him to say ok we'll pull our
missiles out and it was big egg and
Khrushchev his face back in the Soviet
Union one tidbit about that the
documents that came out in November on
the presidential assassination do see
just this past November yes a couple
months ago do seem to indicate that
Khrushchev gave the order after that
humiliation to all networks globally the
Kennedy should be assassinated in Lee
Harvey Oswald may have begun his
preparations because of that director
Wow all right so I do want to talk about
the assassination obviously and even
just the way you said that there's so
much of it it's hard to piece together
and how far do you want to go down the
rabbit hole and follow the conspiracies
and all that but we will get to that but
what what was the final moment that got
Khrushchev to turn down I mean did
Kennedy basically say well I know
there's the line of course but was it
really communicated like this is going
to be World War three well I think to
answer that question we have to speak
Russian and have access to the archives
because I think what happened is that
Khrushchev felt pressure at home as a
lot of people have said Soviet Union
really was a status quo
in the politburo began asking Khrushchev
are you gonna take our lives away from
us you're gonna take our summer docas on
the caspian sea away from us and our our
10% of us in the soviet union who have a
nice life
what are you doing would you please back
down it seems that whatever Kennedy was
doing the real folding happened on the
Soviet side and Khrushchev was not the
first among equals I mean he did not he
was barely premier the Soviet Union so
it seems that and we don't have enough
information on this because it's behind
these source walls that the Russians
back down because they realize
Khrushchev was acting crazy yeah this
may sound like an amateur question but
did they ever actually speak the two of
them through translators was there ever
or everything goes through the
communication after review there's a
great book on this called one hell of a
gamble which has all the documents this
amazing book by Ernest maelzel a column
in the 1990s so let's look that up yeah
yeah how much after the Cuban Missile
Crisis I mean that really changed
everything in American foreign policy
right I mean it really was a huge
catalyst for a lot well we argue in our
book the thing the big change
foreign policy wise came a year later
when Kennedy countenanced and assisted
in the assassination of the South
Vietnamese president cm in November just
a couple weeks before Kennedy's
assassination and that seems to have
been the tipping point of Vietnam I'm
telling you we have been listening to a
lot of the Kennedy tape such a hit with
McNamara and everything else it is true
that Kennedy had no real interest in a
long-term war in Southeast Asia you know
he didn't what on earth he was doing
helping to assassinate cm and I have no
idea and that was a big mistake
so was that really just because he had
this again he had this thing drilled
into him from his father from childhood
about communism and maybe that overrode
the intellectual part of him that said
let's not get into these intractable
wars yeah I think I think GM in Vietnam
was one of those people that Madden
Kennedy because he and like King he
didn't want you to bring him into into
his circle and then have you burned him
you know Jim was to see the you know
American guy yeah he's our guy in South
Vietnam and he just kept alienating
people and making life difficult for the
monks and era and Kenny's like hey you
supposed to be our guy and
John F Kennedy yeah so at some point
Kennedy will break and just okay you're
gone gone and this phone meant
assassinated and that is rare in the
Kennedy ambit's and it ended up being
not good for American and Vietnamese
fortunes for the next you know 10 years
yeah what else do we need to know about
just sort of the the personal side in
terms of what was going on in the White
House during those years yeah I mean he
ran an elegant White House and all that
he did have his kids girlfriends really
kind of did that that side of him did
desecrate the White House and I think we
have done how much people know I think
it's hard to for people to understand in
a modern sense of what could it for
social media and for everyone had a
phone and all that like what did the
average person know about that at the
time or what was the media even saying
right about that well kind of the wisdom
of crowds I think the electorate largely
understood what was going on even though
there's no hard evidence in the papers
and so forth and there really wasn't any
hard evidence I mean now we know about
his swimming nude and this is with the
pools and the Secret Service having to
hold his drinks and all that stuff and
we know all about that now you Judith
Exner may have been killed by the
Communists because she was a plant and
all that not your affection everybody
Gifford Pinchot's nice I believe that
because Kennedy had so many kind of
crazy Affairs in the White House the
press felt that it was burned like we're
not allowed to report this and that's
really what gave us Watergate cuz
Nixon's things were small in comparison
and the press was like we got burned
them we're not gonna get burned again
wow that's fascinating I've never heard
anyone lay it out like that so basically
they kind of played along with JFK
because they were trying to be nice
maybe he was a little bit of air guys
sort of but then but they felt
embarrassed by it I mean they felt use
yeah I mean we're just shutting up about
this yeah and then the next time a
suggestion of that came around they just
went with a sledgehammer
interesting that's really interesting
sorry so obviously we have to talk about
the assassination tell me a little bit
just in the weeks leading up to it and
what was going on in the press
yeah I think that was really Kennedy's
highest time as president Thurston
Clarke has written a great book about
Kennedy's last hundred days from August
to November 1963 but he really was
coming into his own yeah I I think
that's true actually he kept talking to
The Secret Service agent hey isn't this
a great day to be alive I mean he was
really into it his tax hat was going
through so right Scott was going through
the Soviets were gone he just says ZM
that's a footnote so how public was that
by the way was that I was public it was
completely public well no it was
presented as a palace coup that it was
internal so the American fingerprints
were not clear at the time in his
ambassador his new ambassador Henry
Cabot Lodge who he defeated in the
Senate race and fifties was kind of the
fall guy so it appears that he put
somebody in and sat in Saigon who would
have to endure the dirty work so aside
from that Kennedy's enjoying watching
Polaris Mitchell missile launches and
he's laughing at the Senate Finance
Committee which is trying to hold up his
tax cut and it's just like you guys
could try to hold it up and you know I'm
gonna win
so he's really kind of coming into his
own and then November 22nd yeah so what
was it you know I don't know I didn't
know how to ask this question properly
cuz you see everyone seen so much about
it but the new starts breaking and it's
hard to imagine what breaking news would
be like at that time now right can you
kind of frame that a little bit yeah we
can see these they're on you know
YouTube so with soap operas back then
we're live so there would be live actors
yeah you know acting out the soap opera
and they were broken into you can watch
this again on the internet right now
with bulletins from Walt from Walter
Cronkite and so forth saying that
there's been an incident Dallas
president's been shot and then they
would go back to the live acting and
then the actors would just start acting
again about the drama of the soap opera
but it took about probably about 45
minutes to an hour for for people to
realize that it happened to you yeah
when did the conspiracies start popping
like immediately where people going
something is wrong here you know why was
he taking this sort of circular
rootin around with the topless car and
all of that stuff like people
immediately doing that well yeah I mean
the trip to Dallas itself was
controversial it was in the planning in
october/november because Dallas was a
hotbed of kind of what we might call
white supremacy and people worried well
and Kennedy said it's not country down
there they're kind of anti Canada even
though they voted for Kennedy because of
Johnson on the ticket so everyone was
worried about his not getting a good
reception in Texas from that kind of
called em racist you know whites if you
want to use those terms but the trip was
totally successful on those counts he
went to Fort Worth than a huge
celebration and he went to Dallas and
everyone loved him and the last words
perhaps spoken to John F Kennedy were
from Connolly's wife in the car well
it's all over now and you can't say that
Texas doesn't love you and then he was
blown away Wow incredible so you know I
think the first time that I paid it to
end the attention to this was probably
in high school when I saw the movie JFK
I assume you've seen yes yes so how far
is as someone that really cares about
this and a story and all that I mean how
far down all these rabbit holes are you
willing to go it sounds like some of its
still unfolding as new documents still
come out but just for you as someone
that sure that it's interested in this
hmm yeah I mean I think there are couple
aspects of the assassination that we
have to take seriously that we have to
kind of lose our sophistication about Oh
Oswald acted alone now hold it Dealey
Plaza is the best place possible for an
assassination that's where it happened
that should interest us in terms of
conspiracy theories can you explain why
I mean there's that slow turn there's
just the points of yeah these you know
oh there's a it's at the end of the
parade route so the parade is over and
then there has to be a right turn and a
left turn that goes then downhill so the
parade's over which means the intensity
of the experience is over and the Secret
Service's interest will start to wane
and that was absolutely essential in the
assassination then so there's that
setting then there was a school book
depository right there with an
aggressive and an overpass to
Stemmons freeway well it's a perfect
place for assassination so therefore we
should stop this pseudo sophistication
about Oswald acted alone the other thing
too is Kennedy was absurdly good at
making enemies I mean he just made
enemies I mean his father made enemies
for a living yeah so by the way we've
talked in a forty-five or fifty minutes
and we haven't even said in military
industrial complex one rabbit obviously
had some sort of issues within which we
can touch on it yeah right so so in Oz
Walt also had connections to beat the
band with the mob the Soviets Cubans you
know I mean so that's also very heute
phille Jack Ruby Oz what was killed Jack
Ruby has connections to beat the band so
these are all suggestive nonetheless
James Pearson's book Camelot in the
Cultural Revolution is the best book
ever written but about the Kennedy
assassination and it is about the
liberal reaction to the Kennedy
assassination because liberals to this
day have pinned it on the white
supremacists in Dallas and that's just
crazy he was killed because he was a
cotton because there was an
anti-communist I mean that's pretty
clear that Lee Harvey Oswald killed John
F Kennedy because John F Kennedy was
anti-communist and we now are starting
to piece together that he may have felt
he was acting on orders from the Soviet
Union we may have felt that's an
interesting way of phrasing it what do
you mean may have felt well oswald was
quite a character and what was going on
in his head we don't know we do know
that he met he went to the cute the
cuban embassy to meet a soviet
assassination expert in september 1963
the documents that just came out imply
that it was understood in late 1962 that
Nikita Khrushchev after getting burned
in the Cuban Missile Crisis may have
sent out some kind of broad order into
the global Soviet Network that it would
be desirable if President Hayes were
assassinated and that order may have
been called back because of pressure
within the Politburo at Chris Jeff
you're still acting like a nut
Khrushchev was forced out in 1964 but
once you squeeze the toothpaste out of
the tube it's done hard to get it back
in so it may be this is speculation but
grounded in some sources yeah that
Oswald was part of that initial outreach
and then
not have stopped and then went ahead
with it yeah so basically you're willing
to go down these these routes you sort
of have to do it I mean the more I read
about this and the more of these
documentaries I watch you know I've got
a cross Hagenbach right there and I
always quote you know extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence we
have the extraordinary evidence but
there were so many pieces in LA here
yeah that that make it seem hard to
believe yeah I think the one thing that
is firming up pretty well is that Oswald
killed Kennedy because he perceived
Kennedy to be anti-communist so it was
the left that killed Kennedy because
Kennedy was too right-wing
that's been lost over the last 50 some
years but that is firming up through a
lot of sources that's the most important
thing I think to conclude then with the
deep story of Oswald's connections are
okay that's interesting from the grassy
knoll no there's no shot from the grassy
knoll it's impossible anyone's been the
dealer plaza realizes that's the
physical impossibility all that stuff it
does appear very clearly that Oswald
fired this bullet see at the traffic
light then he hit Kennedy in the neck
then he hit Kennedy and the is very the
Magic Bullet that's very easy to see
with a heavy case bullet
full-metal-jacket yeah that will act
that way
the ballistics aren't a question Oswald
shot Kennedy what was it like after
there's a few weeks after the
assassination yeah Johnson was
disoriented
you know his staff of the Kennedys
people wanted to resign that and like
Johnson
the one thing he realized though is that
I have to act to make to memorialize
Kennedy and the one specific step he
took was he told the Senate guess what
you're doing you're passing his tax cut
right now which they did because he
could intimidate the Senate that gave us
the tax cut of 1964 and then Kennedy's
promise was fulfilled and that 5% growth
kept cruising through the 60s yeah what
was the general even taking it away from
the political side the general feeling
in the country after that yeah this
whole thing about lost innocence I was
just in Fort Worth a couple weeks ago
and I can't but Lee Fort Worth and
Dallas have a big rivalry Fort Worth
thinks it's much better than tennis
where it's 30 miles away and everywhere
in Fort Worth there are these reminders
of Kennedy's last
but when America was innocent were in
Fort Worth and then he went to Dallas
where he was killed
so that myth of American innocence is
perpetuated I don't think it's
particularly makes a lot of sense in
terms of first of all Kennedy was killed
because he was anti-communist right so I
know that the air to make sense on that
grounds - and I mean look the civil
rights movement you know which was a
great benefit to the United States will
then push through and flourished after
1963 so that kind of lost innocence I've
never quite understood yeah so basically
the the three markers really are the
economic stuff the tax cuts the civil
rights stuff and and the Cuban Missile
Crisis is there anything else we're
missing in there that that's important
well Vietnam
I mean Kennedy would have never let
Vietnam be the disaster it was he would
have never let that happen so Oliver
Stone is completely wrong that you know
that Kenny was killed by right-wingers
who wanted the Vietnam War but it is I
think inescapable to conclude that
Kennedy would not have presided over the
Vietnam War and like Johnson did yeah
I'm curious as a historian and someone
that deeply cares about this so when you
see all of these movies I mean we make
everything into movies now this JFK and
there's Lincoln and everything now
there's like 18 Winston Churchill is
just there and all that stuff
how much is that concern you like at
some level it's great your people are
getting yeah basic ideas about this
stuff but then in a case of the JFK
movie which I really loved by the way
and I can yes you can see I can play
those conspiracy games but that it also
is hinting at you know there's a real
implication that Johnson maybe it's
something to do with it yeah in the JFK
movie and all that stuff so how much
does that worry you that we get all of
our information now from movies and Doc
you know play coming history originated
in the Stone Age around campfires tell
me stories about I mean it's not a
closet an academic subject
I mean academics have a lot to say but
there has to be very you know good
interaction healthy interaction between
all these kind of so-called vulgar forms
of history which are wonderful a better
in certain way than academic history
just that Oliver Stone's great movie
maker I mean love his movies and
toons incredible movie the others but he
has an extra grind about Vietnam I mean
it was the capitalist who gave it to us
it was the right to gave it to us no if
you kept the anti-communist president's
and you got to realize he was anti
communist he would have realized how to
deal with that crisis mmm all right so
to wrap this all up I thought the the
right way to end this would be we've
talked a little bit about the sort of
modern-day context and the modern-day
lens on some of the stuff and you've
referenced how sort of the parties have
kind of flipped some of the things that
JFK was saying then would not be things
that Democrats would say now what do you
think his political alignments would be
these days right if John F Kennedy had
lived I don't think the Democratic Party
would have flipped so let's say John F
Kennedy has two term presidency somehow
we don't really have a Vietnam War he
you know his ex-president 1969 did the
Democrats spend the next 20 30 years
saying that Kennedy tax cut had nothing
to do with cutting the top rate no he
would have enforced discipline on that
conversation and the Democrats would
have been born along as the party of tax
cuts so that investment flows into the
real world there are lots of jobs for
the regular guy so no I think the
Democratic Party would have been a lot
different if he had lived Wow
so so he really was the less is it fair
to say then you think that he was sort
of the last somewhat small Democrat
small government Democrat at some level
yeah I think what happened is that the
left took advantage of the assassination
because Kennedy wasn't around to defend
himself specifically because of the
assassination the left said aha
we can misrepresent his record we can
hold him highs some kind of big
government liberal and then he became
that in Caroline and John John were kind
of callow enough to go along with that
Ted certainly and that became the icon
of John F Kennedy John Kennedy himself
would have never let that happen
so I'm trying to place where he would be
at right now and I'm guessing soaring so
if he was basically for tax cuts he
believes in a strong military at some
level because he was fighting communism
yet also had all these issues with the
military inducts industrial complex and
trying to figure out what how would you
frame that type of political person
these days I it's like sort of
libertarian but then with
a little bit of a neocon yeah well these
days would be very different I don't
think we would have had Bill Clinton
because Kennedy would have been around
to be the elder party leader and people
wouldn't have been able to get away with
a lot of the misrepresentation that they
have in order to make the modern
Democratic Party that's interesting so
did the assassination and then
subsequently the whole family sort of
falling apart and Robert Kennedy
everything else that I mean that really
did set it set the nation in a strange
way but it really did something crazy to
the Democratic Party inherently because
its whole machine yeah sort of
RFK yeah RFK probably was going to have
another marginal tax cut
then he's blown away in 1968 Ted Kennedy
continued to talk about tax cuts through
the mid 70s and then only in 1980 became
this kind of big status government type
so yeah we could have it could have been
a lot different if the Kennedy boys had
lived yeah do you think we're done with
the dynasties I mean it seems to me now
that you know Hillary lost so it seems
like perhaps we've had our last Clinton
although I'm sure Chelsea's gonna run
for Senator from New York or something
like that yeah you know the Bush family
really after Jeb did so horribly it
seems like that might be done although
George P Bush down in Texas
maybe will do something maybe Trump is
gonna step aside and let it all go run
next time or who knows right but I sense
that the dynasty thing really has
people's sort of exhaustion yeah
with families that have this much power
it really has reached a peak and that
would seem to be a salubrious phenomenon
I think again the assassination is at
fault here if John F Kennedy had had two
full terms would the nation have felt
the obligation to find out about all
these other Kennedys probably not but
the cutting short of that political
career I think is what gave life to all
these other Kennedys running for office
Wow it's it's fascinating stuff
well I've thoroughly enjoyed this we're
going to put the link to your book right
down below so for more on JFK's life and
legacy
check out Brian's book JFK and the
Reagan Revolution a secret history of
American prosperity which again we're
going to link to right down below
[Music]
you